Verne Lundquist back here in the program
how are you Verne rich I'm doing great
and it's always a privilege to chat with
you actress after something like we all
witnessed yesterday yeah I'm right back
at you I feel the same way and I greatly
appreciate that so I'll ask you the
open-ended question here about where
where does this rank burn do you think
it's it's up there
you know I've my fallback position on
that question because I've been so
blessed not only here but in different
than using different sports but my
number one has always gone back to 86
with Jack and and I was lucky enough to
have the call of the platform 17 that
gave him the lead my number two in golf
has always been 2005 when Tiger chipped
in at 16 and I was lucky enough to be
there and believe me
you jumped up when when he hit that shot
and it came to rest I had to push the
COFF key because I could feel myself
tearing up and I thought we're not gonna
have a breakdown on national television
that was not the appropriate and so I
called key down until I got my composure
back and the enormity of this story in
so many respects is is overwhelming when
and I've watched the guys on Golf
Channel our guys and and Tiger did
something very very gracious yesterday
when we did our repeat after going
through the press room and all the other
requests he had he went back down to
Butler cabin for a second time and went
live with Jim Nantz and Nick Faldo and
it was I don't know the tiger would have
done something like that in 2005 but
that's a factor in why we all love I
think everybody loves what happened
yesterday
because it's just a magnificent story of
not only athletic accomplishment but
personal Redemption fern Lundqvist here
on the Rich Eisen show described the
scene to me
looking around from your perspective in
the tower just watching everybody go
nuts when that ball almost hold out on
16 please
well it's I'm very very prejudiced
obviously but I've been sitting at that
spot for twenty years now and in my view
yes I know 11 and 12 is very special
obviously surrounding 18 but at 16
they almost encircle all of the green
around the pond and behind it up on the
hill I could sit behind the tower and
look at second and third shots at 15 and
the putts obviously I can turn behind me
and physically see the sixth hole and
what's going on there and I can walk to
tee shots in 17 so I don't think anybody
who's privileged to be at Augusta
National has a better viewing spot can
make and and to watch the emotion it's
so different and and he's so different
and I think that's what makes this such
a an amazingly compelling story that we
can all embrace he's you know and he's
he said I'm I'm a better human being
Jim Nantz I thought had a great day
and he had a great great note when he
did the interview with Tiger Live that
said surely the son had written his dad
a note and said dad my mom I guess for
Christmas I'm not sure my my one wish is
to see you win a golf tournament and
Tiger alluded to that at the open last
year he had his kids Charlie and Sam
with him and he fell short
so this and the hug the embrace that he
gave both of those guys and his mother
was something that we'll all cherish for
as long as we have memories Verne
Lundquist here on the Rich Eisen show
what are the you know some are obvious
some might not be which is why I'm
asking you the similarities between
Tiger 2019 and Jack 1980
well age in part I listen to the Golf
Channel guys and they got hold of jack
on the phone last night in the Bahamas
he had been here during the week and I
had to see him after the champions
dinner on Tuesday night and and he said
he watched all the turn from from the
tiny the way Jack put it from the time
Mullen or I found the molineres on the
water at 12 and when Tiger out on the
green Jack said I knew Tiger was gonna
win this thing
Jack was 46 tigers 43 so that two oldest
champions ever at Augusta they are
arguably the two greatest golfers who
have ever lived all of a sudden I was
among those I didn't think he had a
chance
two years ago coming back and playing
and I didn't believe rich that he was a
changed person I now understand that he
truly is that he's he's changed the way
he approaches his life and and his
interaction with people that may be the
most endearing thing about all this and
then the physical accomplishment of the
way that was was comparable to what Jack
jackdaw shot 30 on the back nine at the
age of 46 that's and and he said
yesterday you know nobody wants to have
their records broken but he said I was
cheering for Tiger like everybody also
Tigers not got 15 majors and he still
creature jack and I'm still inclined to
not I'm inclined to not believe he's
gonna catch Jack but I'm less so
inclined that I was yesterday morning at
9 o'clock yeah I'm with you to Verne
Verne Lundquist here in the Rich Eisen
show and again I don't know how much of
the broadcast that you are taking in
because obviously you've got stuff right
there in front of you there were two
aces on 16 yesterday in particular but
again that the fact that so many of
those he was competing
yesterday put it in the water on 12 and
then he did the typical Jack Nicklaus
shot which is just put it between the
two bunkers be safe play it safe get
your three get out of Dodge and win the
tournament and and and I'm wondering if
you've seen a that sort of progression
in Tigers play as well from where you
first saw him and witnessed yesterday
well what I saw yesterday Jack Jack
listen to me I'll take a cab
no no I appreciate I'll take his Bahamas
yacht to Vern I'll do that okay I'm
battling bronchitis anyway well you know
yesterday I'll tell you that in the
whole week was great
physically was something I mean he told
the people at the champions dinner two
years ago I'm done and and I don't think
any of them got it and I think we all
believed that he would never compete and
so to go through and we all know about
the personal problems and his desire to
overcome that but the physical
difficulty of the surgeries the back
surgeries the knees are and and I mean I
saw the interview that he did Saturday
afternoon about well how do you prepare
since were going early tomorrow
well Tommy you get up he said I'll be up
at 3:45 in the morning to do his
stretching exercises man that's a guy
commitment I don't know that many many
men have well Vern it was just great
watching it again and just just great
the fact that you're in that tower and
that you can connect these two
generations these two generational
performances it's just really neat man
and I'm I guess you know you you have
the ability to just sit back and take it
all in it's great well and and you know
how I feel about you and I'm honored to
be on with you especially since we tend
to do this after great moments in sports
that we both enjoy thank you very really
appreciate the the the time
no let's chat again down the road
appreciate it you got it promise you bet
that's Verne Lundquist here for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app